So the fault tolerance techniques that are used
often are checkpointing where we can save the
state of the system periodically, then we detect
errors and restore the state of the system
once we detect an error. This type of
technique works really well for many transient and
also intermittent faults. So the idea here is
that you will save the state of the system
when the system is functioning normally. If a fault occurs
we will try to detect errors that result from that and
restore the system into a state that was not affected by
the fault. So if the the fault is transient it will
not happen again and our system goes back to functioning normally.
If the fault is intermittent, then this might happen a few
times, until we reach the time when the fault is no
longer going to be activated, and then again we will function normally.
So the system continues to function normally, if
we can quickly recover from each of the
faults, so that it doesn't affect the overall
availability and reliability of the system. If checkpointing takes
too long, then this type of recovery has
to be treated as service interruption. But if checkpointing
and detection and restoring of the state are
very, very fast it may be that the promised
service is never disrupted. So for example, if the
system is supposed to answer all the web queries
within, let's say one second, if we manage to do all of this in such a way that
we still respond to all of the things that
we got in one second, then there has been
no serious interruption. We can use two-way redundancy, where
two modules do the same work. Then we compare their
results, and we roll back if the results are different. So this is really
an error detection technique, and it needs
a recovery technique such as checkpointing. Similarly,
checkpointing is a recovery technique. It needs
something like two-way redundancy to actually detect
errors and while these techniques recover and
detect things separately, we can also have
something like three-way redundancy which can both detect and
recover some faults. And in this case three modules
or more will do the same work and then
vote for what the correct result should be. So
if one module is malfunctioning then the two others
will still produce the same result and that result
will be elected by the vote as the overall
correct result. So the fault in one module becomes
an error in that module but doesn't become
an error at the system level, because at the
output of these three modules and their voter, we
always have an error free result. This technique is
expensive. You pretty much need three times the hardware
plus the voter that you would have without some
fault tolerance techniques. But, in return, it can tolerate
any fault that can occur in any one of
the modules. So as long as the fault that you have is affecting only one module,
we can tolerate that fault. Even, for example,
if that one module is purposely designed to be
malicious. because the correct two are still going to
out vote it and we never really see
whatever that module is trying to produce in
our overall results. But what happens if two modules
fail, in that case we no longer can tolerate that.